welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the queen of sex education Amy
Lu controversial statement to make josh
is it be queen legally what of the Queen
yes is subjective to clean please he
said this thing to me last yeah when we
met when you first got this character
and you said it was the most liberating
experience ever because it's your first
on-screen character and then you're
having a sex scene and your life you
have to get and you like lick she said I
think like she's got my tits out you did
it with a band got my tits out yeah
what has your own relationship with body
image been like in order to you to get
to that situation where you can be like
yes I'm totally comfortable to do this I
knew it wasn't gratuitous and I knew it
was always helping the story along and
because I wanted to tell the story as
honestly and as well as I could
it kind of gave me that really great
push to go no I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
I'm going to do it and it was such a
safer environment from the get-go with
those sex scenes that it just felt like
the perfect opportunity to challenge
myself because I never would have
thought in a million years that I will
be able to do that like I have suffered
with body dysmorphia my whole life so
alright I remember that day thinking
just think of and also in my
masturbation montage I was like just
that because all the unflattering angles
I mean nothing and I remember I remember
thinking of it think think of the young
girls that are gonna be watching this
and going oh thank god that's what I do
or you know it's not we don't always
look perfect you know I remember before
the first sex scene I thought right okay
I'll start eating I'll start just eating
salads every day and I just didn't and
making that was such a turning point for
me was making that decision to go
actually I'm not gonna alter how my body
looks before this scene because this is
how my body looks and that it's a
terrifying thing but having a character
as well helps you a lot with that
because you go well Amy look
like this I am Amy I am originating this
character this is who she is and this is
what she looks like and I'm just gonna
own that and that helped me so much I
would you be the type that you know when
I when you younger and I just watched
eighth grade when she goes to the pool
party and she's just so I hated pool
parties all of that stuff anyhow those
girls that would just be so confidently
whipped off their tops and they're being
a little bikinis and I would just be
like I'm gonna wear a t-shirt and and
even when I was at my absolute skinniest
I would still be terrified to ever show
parts of my body that I didn't think
were perfect
and I think learning that perfection
doesn't exist and the beauty lies in
those flaws and those individuality 's
and those nuances it's just the most
liberating thing ever because you're
striving for something that doesn't
exist
your whole life it doesn't actually
exist this goal is completely
unattainable because you're never gonna
look to you what you think perfect is
until you just go oh I am the way I am
is absolutely great and it's still a
bloody battle because I'll still see
pictures and I'll go move that wasn't a
flattering angle or but then I just
think no I have to I'm definitely
training myself how to thinking like a
go down a positive path way instead of a
negative because an immediate reaction
for years was just to like berate myself
when I think back now it's so hard to
myself like your disguise I actually
wrote on my mirror when I was younger
fat in lipstick so that every day I'd go
to it and go okay you just remind
yourself that that's what you are sorry
okay
oh my heart okay yeah when you look in
the mirror and you go I feel fat feeling
fat is not that's not a feeling you can
feel full or you can feel like bloated
or empty or empty or hungry but you
can't feel that it's it's an adjective
an aesthetic thing and we demonize that
word so much but I think it's so amazing
that you can sit here now and say this
staff yeah and you've been liberated
yeah through this thing I'm actually so
damn proud of yourself Han and I've
spoken about it Lots and it is the best
most rewarding thing when I see you
girls comment you know this has helped
me so much with my eating disorder thank
you so much and it's it it makes it so
much more meaningful than just oh I'm an
actor like I think it's encouraged me to
just strive to tell the most I don't
want to be involved in like shallow
frivolous superficial stories like I
actually feel empowered now to say if I
see a script out I feel like I can go no
I don't want to tell this story I don't
think it's got a social conscience
engaging all the time with the bigger
picture and not just your own vanity and
your own insecurities it really it just
releases you yeah have you Dow with that
such a game-changing year would you say
I think it was so helpful that I went
straight into another job after sex
education I think if I'd have just had
time and space to dwell on how big sex
ed was I would have just got really
overwhelmed
I've definitely still got a lot to learn
about retaining stuff from me like my
instinct is to always kind of share I'm
a very explosive person learning that
that in itself is slightly a persona and
that in itself is actually a mask
sometimes like sometimes the sharing is
kind of covering up or the [ __ ] I'm
trying to just realize that I don't have
to give it my hundred ten percent energy
and every encounter that I ever have
because it's kind of impossible to be so
enthusiastic and so energetic every time
I see someone who recognizes me from sex
ad is quite draining yeah especially
because she has the same name as me yes
so it's like Amy you're like oh my god
there's no risk oh I think can be quite
claustrophobic I think especially in
these kind of situations you learned
that you are you're kind of like number
one Ally as well right yeah have you
learned that it's about trusting and
giving yourself over to the right people
and retaining yourself from the wrong
because I think it's hard to
differentiate sometimes especially
because of sex education because people
come over to you and they tell you how
much they love you and it's like a
stranger but they don't love me they
love the character we are very
intertwined because Amy feels like her
thing that she has to offer is a big
house for people to have parties in and
kind of this carefree easy breezy
attitude and in season two that's really
challenged because she goes through this
trauma and it's like she doesn't know
how to navigate because she can't hide
that she's sad so she just isolates
herself because it's like I don't want
you to see me like this because then I'm
I'm not like a valid person I'm not
valuable there can be a tendency for me
and my own life to do a little bit of
that like if I'm not on top form
I'd like I'll just hide away I'll just
hide away because no one really wants to
see me like this but actually if they
have friends and they love you they do
want to see you in whatever state they
will see you in your whole entirety yeah
exactly but I think that's why it got
confused for me you imagine you had
that's my thing now is that I'm just
really an open book yeah but then you
might want to close the book I just want
to close the book for a little bit but
you feel too scared to because then you
scare people are going to go what's
happened why shouldn't this but actually
it's okay it's giving us our permission
to not be happy all the time
you're allowed to have different
emotions other than pure joy a bit weird
I don't marry live yeah having to be
like on all the time and everyone's like
you're the fun one
anyway you don't be the fun one anymore
everyone's like what's wrong with you
yeah you're like I've absolutely if I
give me ten seconds no you quiet for a
second yeah okay well you should be so
done practice out there because you've
obviously been on this amazing journey
you got to this point when your Sat hair
is this really amazing empowered women
in your own right
so no out of you thank you